Ensuite, les capteurs dont ils sont équipés
finissent par revenir très cher :
un scanneur laser, une caméra, plus les processeurs.
Cela augmente encore le prix du robot.
Donc nous nous sommes posé la question :
quel bien de consommation peut-on acheter dans un magasin d'électronique,
qui soit bon marché, léger, programmable, et dispose de capteurs ?
Et nous avons inventé le téléphone volant.
(Rires)
Ce robot utilise donc un Samsung Galaxy, que vous pouvez acheter en magasin,
et tout ce dont vous avez besoin est de télécharger notre application.
Vous pouvez voir ce robot lire les lettres « TED »,
observer les coins du T et du E,
et voler en autonomie, en se repérant grâce à ça.
La manette est juste là au cas où : si le robot bascule du côté obscur,
Giuseppe pourra l'éliminer.
(Rires)
En plus de ces petits robots,
nous travaillons sur des comportements plus agressifs, comme celui-ci.
Ce robot se déplace à deux ou trois mètres par seconde,
et il tangue et roule agressivement quand il change de direction.
L'essentiel, c'est que nous pouvons construire de robots plus petits,
qui se déplacent très vite dans des milieux sans structure.
Dans la vidéo suivante,
tout comme cet aigle coordonne avec grâce
ses ailes, ses yeux et ses serres pour sortir sa proie de l'eau,
vous pouvez voir notre robot partir à la pêche.
(Rires)
Dans son cas, il attrape un sandwich au vol.
Ce robot vole donc à environ 3 m/s, c'est-à-dire plus vite que
quelqu'un qui marche, en coordonnant ses bras, ses pinces et son vol
avec un timing à la seconde près qui lui permet d'effectuer cette manœuvre.
Dans une autre expérience,
je veux vous montrer comme le robot adapte son plan de vol
pour contrôler son chargement en suspension,
qui est plus long que la hauteur de la structure dans laquelle il doit passer.
Pour accomplir cet exploit,
il doit tanguer, ajuster son altitude, et faire passer le chargement
avec un effet de balancier.
Mais bien sûr, nous avons voulu faire encore plus petit,
en nous inspirant particulièrement des abeilles.
Regardez les abeilles, dans cette vidéo ralentie.
Elles sont si petites, et soumises à si peu d'inertie,
(Rires)
qu'elles n'en ont rien à faire : elles rebondissent sur ma main.
Ce petit robot imite le comportement des abeilles.
Et plus il est petit, mieux c'est,
car l'inertie diminue avec la taille.
Et plus l'inertie est faible...
(Le robot bourdonne - Rires)
Plus l'inertie est faible, mieux vous résistez aux collisions.
Et cela vous rend plus solide.
Donc nous construisons des petits robots, comme des abeilles.
Celui-ci, par exemple, ne pèse que 25 g,
ne consomme que 6 W,
et peut voler jusqu'à 6 m/s.
Donc, si on met ça à l'échelle,
cela correspond à un Boeing 787 qui irait à 3 fois la vitesse du son.
(Rires)
Je vais vous montrer un exemple.
Voici probablement la première collision en vol planifiée, ralentie 20 fois.
La vitesse relative des robots est de 2 m/s,
ce qui illustre ce principe de base.
La cage en fibre de carbone, qui pèse 2 g, évite aux hélices de s'emmêler,
mais l'essentiel du choc est absorbé, et le robot réagit à la collision.
Donc, plus petit veut aussi dire plus sûr.
Dans mon labo, pour développer ces robots,
nous avons commencé avec des gros,
et maintenant nous en faisons des tout petits.
Et si vous faites un graphique de notre consommation de pansements,
vous verrez qu'elle est quasiment nulle maintenant.
Tout ça parce que ces robots sont vraiment sûrs.
Leur petite taille a ses inconvénients,
mais la nature a trouvé des moyens de les compenser.
L'idée est de former de larges groupes, des essaims.
Donc, au labo, on essaye de faire la même chose, et de créer des essaims de robots.
C'est un gros défi,
parce qu'il faut réfléchir en termes de réseau de robots.
Et pour chaque robot,
il faut penser à la combinaison des sens, de la communication, de la programmation.
Le réseau devient vite difficile à contrôler et manœuvrer.
Donc nous nous inspirons des principes d'organisation de la nature
pour développer nos algorithmes.
La première idée est que chaque robot prenne son voisin en compte.
Il doit être capable de sentir et de communiquer avec ses voisins.
Cette vidéo illustre cette idée.
Il y a quatre robots,
et l'un d'entre eux a été littéralement détourné par un agent humain.
Mais puisque les robots interagissent les uns avec les autres,
ils localisent leur voisin,
et suivent le mouvement.
Et une seule personne peut contrôler tout un réseau.
Encore une fois, ce n'est pas parce que tous les robots savent où ils vont.
Ils réagissent juste à la position de leurs voisins.
(Rires)
La prochaine expérience illustre le deuxième principe d'organisation.
Ce principe, c'est celui de l'anonymat.
L'idée est la suivante :
les robots se fichent de l'identité de leurs voisins.
On leur a demandé de former un cercle,
et quel que soit le nombre de robots ajoutés à la formation,
ou retirés,
chaque robot réagit simplement par rapport à son voisin.
Il sait qu'il doit former un cercle,
mais en collaborant avec ses voisins,
il forme le cercle sans coordination globale.
Donc, si on tient compte de ces deux idées,
la troisième est que nous donnons à ces robots
des descriptions mathématiques de la formation à exécuter.
Ces formes peuvent varier dans le temps,
et vous verrez les robots commencer par un cercle,
pour passer à un triangle, s'étirer en ligne,
et finalement revenir à une ellipse.
Et ils font ça avec la même coordination instantanée
que l'on trouve dans les vrais essaims, dans la nature.
Mais pourquoi travailler avec des essaims ?
Laissez-moi vous parler des deux applications qui nous intéressent le plus.
La première concerne l'agriculture,
qui est certainement le défi mondial le plus important.
Comme vous le savez,
une personne sur sept est en situation de malnutrition.
Nous cultivons presque toutes les terres cultivables.
L'efficacité de nombreux systèmes mondiaux ne cesse de s'améliorer,
mais notre système de production est en déclin.
Cela vient principalement du manque d'eau, des maladies, du changement climatique,
et d'autres facteurs.
Qu'y peuvent les robots ?
Nous avons adopté une approche appelée l'agriculture de précision.
Le principe est de faire voler des robots dans des vergers,
pour construire des modèles informatiques précis de chaque plante.
Comme avec la médecine personnalisée,
où l'on traite chaque patient individuellement,
nous voulons modéliser chaque plante,
pour pouvoir dire à l'agriculteur ce dont elles ont besoin individuellement.
Ici, ce serait de l'eau, de l'engrais ou des pesticides.
Vous pouvez voir un robot se déplacer dans une plantation de pommiers,
et vous apercevrez bientôt deux de ses compagnons,
qui font le même travail à gauche.
En gros, ils sont en train de construire une carte du verger.
A l'intérieur de la carte, il y a une carte de chacun des arbres.
(le robot bourdonne)
Jetons un œil à ces cartes.
Dans la vidéo suivante, vous verrez les caméras utilisées par ce robot.
En haut à gauche, une caméra classique ;
au milieu, une caméra infrarouge ;
et en bas, une caméra thermique.
Sur l'écran principal, vous voyez la reconstruction en 3D
de chaque arbre du verger, créée au fil de l'avancée des capteurs.
Avec ces informations, nous pouvons faire de nombreuses choses.
La première chose, qui est sans doute la plus importante, est très simple :
compter le nombre de fruits sur chaque arbre.
Quand l'agriculteur peut savoir combien de fruits il y a sur chaque arbre,
il peut évaluer le rendement du verger,
et donc optimiser la chaîne de production en aval.
Nous pouvons aussi prendre les mesures des plantes,
les reproduire en 3D,
et ainsi évaluer la taille de la canopée, puis mettre en relation
la taille de la canopée et le nombre de feuilles sur chaque plante.
On appelle cela l'indice de surface feuillue.
Avec cet indice de surface feuillue,
on peut mesurer la capacité de photosynthèse de chaque plante,
ce qui indique leur niveau de santé.
En combinant les informations visuelles et infrarouge,
on peut aussi calculer des indices comme le NDVI.
Dans ce cas, on peut voir
que certaines plantes ne vont pas aussi bien que d'autres.
On peut le voir facilement sur l'image,
qui n'est pas seulement visuelle, mais combine
à la fois les images visuelles et l'infrarouge.
Enfin, une des choses qui nous intéresse est
la détection des premiers symptômes de la chlorose,
on a pris un oranger en exemple,
qui se manifeste par un jaunissement des feuilles.
Les robots qui volent au-dessus des plantes peuvent la repérer facilement,
et informer l'agriculteur qu'il a un problème
dans cette partie du verger.
Ce genre de système peut être très utile,
et nous pensons pouvoir augmenter les rendements d'environ 10 %,
et, surtout, diminuer les dépenses, en eau par exemple, d'au moins 25%.
Tout ça grâce aux essaims de robots volants.
Pour finir, je vous demande d'applaudir ceux qui créent le futur :
Yash Mulgaonkar, Sikang Liu et Giuseppe Loianno,
qui ont réalisé les trois démonstrations que vous avez vues.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)